welcome back everyone to politics now
and the democratic national convention
kicks off tonight
and two southern nevadans will be
prominently featured senator catherine
cortez masto
speaks tonight it is scheduled for six
o'clock and state senator
and senior adviser to the biden campaign
ivana consella
is speaking tomorrow skylar henry has
more on what you can expect from the
unconventional convention
political conventions are a time to
nominate the party's presidential
candidate
and fire up voters and in that way this
year is no different
i just feel the enthusiasm and the
energy not just about what we're
against as a party but really about a
vision for america
that's inclusive but this year as
democrats rally behind joe biden and
kamala harris
things will look a lot different go on
other sports arenas filled with
delegates and balloons
instead the program is mostly virtual
with speakers joining from all 50 states
and u.s
territories i will be speaking
with the statue of liberty looking over
my shoulder
senator bernie sanders and former first
lady michelle obama
are tonight's headliners with speeches
expected to focus on the coronavirus
pandemic
the struggling economy and the country
grappling with race and policing
we're going to rally the american people
around an agenda
and i look forward to doing that the day
after biden is elected
former governor john kasich is also
scheduled to speak tonight the ohio
republican will try to sway gop
voters who may be wavering in the
support of the president president trump
is trying to draw attention from the dnc
coverage with a trip to the battleground
states of minnesota and wisconsin we're
going to be working very hard
we have to we're getting down to final
crunch
we want to be there the democratic party
is hitting back with a new ad in
wisconsin
now trump is coming to wisconsin the ad
calls the visit
a political stunt and it implies the
rally the president held in tulsa
oklahoma helped spread the coronavirus
skyler henry cbs news capitol hill